as this ever happened to you while glass
and plastic and shatter and crack
researchers have been hard at work
developing materials that can be easily
reassembled using strengths of molecules
called polymers healable polymers are
not a new idea but previous versions
were either soft making them impractical
for most applications or they required
high temperatures to merge the pieces
back together using a pair of molecules
linked together researchers have
developed a new kind of semi-transparent
material that maintains both rigidity
and healing properties without requiring
any external heating the key to this
process lies in the design of dense
hydrogen bonds that keep the polymer
together the hydrogen bonds form in such
a way that the polymer doesn't
crystallize giving the change the
ability to move freely and combine when
compressed different kinds of linkers
were tested such as tue g2 and tu c8 but
the best behaved was tu e g3 after being
cut and gently compressed for 30 seconds
a 2 square centimeter sheet can hold 300
grams of weight roughly the same as a
full can of soda and the longer it's
compressed the stronger the bonds become
in the future this rigid polymer could
be used to make robots and other
technology that can be easily repaired
and maybe even let you fix a broken
window
[Music]